Wow bloody hell dear
and this is it Wow Wow
we have five rooms this one is a hundred
thirty books oh wow
you're taller than I am see how it just
lays up there on that on top of that we
don't see the area go the poems too
short my gun you know so look that's
that and this has been here since 2007
and it's writing down let's leave them
there for now let's get some light in
here okay I'm packin yeah that's private
what you mean is private this is my
bedroom Wow this is off-limits it's got
a lock on it
it's like a storage closet but if I'm
paying for the room I'd like to get into
my wardrobe but you're not paying for
that you're paying for everything else
we've got these little things you can
put your suitcase on my clothes your
clothes seriously seriously it's very
inconvenient when there are people here
and I can't get to my clothes but I live
with it I'm gonna hang my clothes in my
wardrobe
18:40 we we use hooks hooks mm-hmm why
don't you get me key to open this I need
to hang my my jacket yeah just have to
use a hook once again this is a rental
you're renting me a room I'm here to
help you and I'd like to use my wardrobe
mm-hmm can I have a look inside then
please because I'm just worried in case
you put somebody in there there yeah
these are all your clothes literally oh
that's it that's it
well there's a few jackets in the
wardrobe upstairs see how another right
above this is another room in another
room that you rent out with a padlock on
mm-hmm
you'll pay $130 for the owners clothes
to stay in the wardrobe that's a first
for me congratulations I feel really
uncomfortable at having my wardrobe full
of all your clothes I can cover it up
but it stays locked so you can just
ignore it can I just have half of this
then do you mind oh okay Shelley Shelley
wanted you to bring some of those
clothes and things down just put them in
my office okay oh my do you see Karen
wearing this stuff what do you mean she
wears two outfits I've never seen
anything other than what she's wearing
and denim and fake it's like government
from the Civil War how'd you ever go
through this stuff Karen you ever think
Wow change color today maybe a bright
color with red or lily season - mm-hmm
so this is your fall look now this is
this is how we hadn´t winter summer it's
usually denim or a beige okay so no no
white after Labor Day then never never
okay thank you thank you what is crazy I
mean I've never met such a basket case
like this in all my life I mean the
place is cluttered and it's almost like
her belongings are everywhere you turn
left to right there's either a basket or
an item of cara's clothing why is that
for the cases what's in here blank more
baskets
my room is cluttered and here look at
that in there oh my God look at all this
stuff
how could you fit all I don't know that
is um definitely took skill and where is
she downstairs else has come up a new
please this is insane
Karen yes okay yes look at all this
stuff shoes handbags scarfs
just smell them it smells like my shoes
they stink my darling they reek
they smell like like my shoes yeah they
shouldn't be in my room I said in my
mind he rented everything except this
wardrobe which I wanna tell me that line
took my money feeding ass